[Music]
brenon so great to be here with you
today thank you so much for having me of
course so talk to me about what exactly
your company does yeah so I'm one of the
co-founders and CEO of a company called
patch okay at patch our core objective
is to scale carbon dioxide removal with
software okay carbon dioxide removal is
a core ingredient to fighting climate
change so when you think about
mitigating the climate crisis there's
two core levers we have to pull the
first is decarbonizing
that looks like rolling out renewable
electricity electrifying vehicles but
then the second piece is removing carbon
from the atmosphere we've been polluting
for the last 150 years and we actually
have to undo some of that pollution in
addition to preventing further pollution
in order to hit our climate goals very
cool now how did you get the idea for
this walk me through your founding story
yeah absolutely so I initially studied
chemical engineering at abigo with the
intention of working in low carbon
energy it's how I thought I was going to
fight the climate crisis it didn't work
out I only got jobs in oil and gas
coming out of school and so instead of
doing that I worked at a wide variety of
tech startups uh for around 8 or nine
years and then back in April of 2020 me
and my co-founder Aon grunfeld really
wanted to start something of our own and
so what we did was we looked at what are
the eight or nine things that need to be
true in order for us to hit our climate
goals going back to those Solutions I
mentioned earlier so renewable energy
Agriculture and carbon dioxide removal
was one of those elements where it felt
like there was no infrastructure to get
it off the ground and we had very little
existing capacity back in 2020 we
weren't even doing one 1,000th of the
amount of carbon dioxide removal we need
to be doing and so we decided to focus
on that area and understand how we could
apply the software skills we learned in
past companies we've worked up before
and apply it to carbon dioxide removal
very cool were the other startups that
you worked in in the energy and climate
space as well or is this a a change for
you uh it's a total change so I used to
work at a company called Shopify it's an
e-commerce platform to help e-commerce
Merchants launch and scale their
business right and then a company called
saer which is a tech enabled Hotel
essentially but what that taught me was
at Shopify was all about building these
vertical platforms to help sellers scale
their business that actually Maps really
similarly to carbon dioxide removal
developers that people selling that
carbon removal capacity yeah and then at
sa we were listing on a variety of
marketplaces um whether that's
booking.com Airbnb and so that
Marketplace understanding actually
mapped really well to some of the
problems we were facing within carbon
markets interesting so say I'm a company
or a consumer of your platform walk me
through like the experience and and how
you're it works yeah absolutely so
typically uh we only work with
corporates and so what will happen is
you'll make some sort of Net Zero
strategy so understanding how am I going
to get from a polluting company to a
company where I have no environmental
impact okay and there's going to be a
few elements to that but it's going to
be primarily focused on Three core steps
understanding what the footprint is
creating a path to decarbonize so
reducing the emissions and then actually
compensating for the remaining emissions
to get to that net in net zero and that
net piece is the part that patch
actually helps with where we give a wide
variety of buyers access to a wide
variety of carbon dioxide removal
Solutions whether that's nature-based
Solutions or even something like direct
air capture which are these big fans
that suck CO2 out of the air very cool
so I feel like I've been hearing about
this more and more recently of course
climate change is top of mine for
everyone so there seems like there's a
lot of other companies out there who are
doing similar things maybe not exactly
how you're doing it talk to me about
your competitors and how you're setting
yourself apart yeah absolutely so the
way to think about patch and what kind
of makes us special is we view our core
customer not as the buyer of carbon
dioxide removal but as the seller of the
capacity because those are folks really
doing the work on the ground and trying
to understand how are we going to
actually deploy reforestation technology
or direct air carbon capture or all
these other Technologies they're the
ones doing the chemical engineering and
operations on the ground and so one of
the first things when we worked with
those folks they told us was we need
sales so we launched that Marketplace
product to understand okay how do we get
more buyers to come to buy from these
folks but then the second piece was okay
now we have all these sales but our
business is complicated there's all this
information complexity I don't know how
to do foreign exchange or payments and
so then we launched a product called
carbon OS which is that kind of Shopify
s platform that vertical SAS platform
for suppliers so the thing that really
differentiates patch is we're really for
the suppliers all the time regardless of
what the buyers actually need
interesting very cool now talk to me
about your fundraising Journey how's
that been for you yeah thankfully it's
gotten easier and easier you know the
first round we raised around $4 and half
million dollars from andreon but that
took a really long time that was during
covid as well from I guess that was June
or June or July of 2020 so big big kind
of drawn out experience um but we've
been fortunate enough to raise from a
really wide variety of folks including
Andre kotu and energize and have raised
around $80 million to dat
um so really thankful to be really well
capitalized particularly in this more
economic uncertain time um so we're just
heads down focused on building and doing
what's best for carbon markets as a
whole nice what has fundraising afforded
you and your company primarily affording
the best talent so climate tech
companies as a whole actually have this
Advantage because apart from maybe AI
it's a highly desirable ecosystem for
Tech workers to work within right people
really want to find a way to apply these
software skills and Technology skills to
a mission that really excites them and
climate change is one of those kind of
top two three missions that most folks
particularly in the Bay Area London New
York really think about and so for us
it's really primarily for it us the
higher the best people we can possibly
find and we're fortunate enough to have
a huge top of funnel because a lot of
people want to work in climate and put
you know their 40 60 hours a week
towards actually a mission that's a
little bit bigger than themselves that
makes a lot of sense now I want to get
some sort of a sense of scale of your
company can you talk to me a bit about
how many users you have or anything like
that that'll show me your size yeah
absolutely so on the buyer side of the
equation we work with around 400
corporates companies as large as eqt or
ban and Company to a smaller startups
you haven't heard of before and then on
the supply side we work with around a
hundred or so carbon credit developers
at various stages of scale as well some
doing a couple hundred thousand tons a
year others doing tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of tons a year so
we have around 400 million tons under
management in the patch platform
holistically that's really cool now a
thing I hear a lot especially from
Founders in the social impact space is
that it's really hard to balance doing
good for the world with running a
profitable business how do you how do
those things compete I guess in your
mind and how do you look at it in how
you run your company yeah absolutely so
I'm a really big believer that markets
are kind of what got us into this
problem as well as what's going to drive
us out of this problem so if you find a
way to align incentives and market-based
Dynamics along with that with the
specific outcome you want you're going
to have a lot of really good result
results and so for us what we've seen is
there's more and more pressure whether
it's from consumers Regulators or
investors on corporates to get their
climate strategy in shape and so for us
thankfully we've been able to really
give these folks uh a kind of extend an
arm to these folks and help them kind of
operationalize some of their carbon
strategy and so it's actually the ROI
for the business is actually quite clear
and so many times we don't really feel
this tension of doing what's good for
the world or what's good for business
because a lot of these businesses are
coming to us asking us how do I how do I
do this thing and we kind of serve it
them on a silver platter hey these are
the three steps you should do and we
make it really easy for them what would
you say is the most challenging part of
running your business it's a great
question you know I think particularly
within carbon markets it's actually
understanding all the moving Parts
within the ecosystem so carbon markets
globally if you include voluntary and
compliance carbon markets are around 900
billion globally but just within
voluntary car carbon what we're focusing
on is actually only 3 or four billion a
year but it's growing really quickly and
so as a result there are new standards
new buyers new sellers new rule sets
that are emerging and so we have to be
incredibly reactive and it creates a
huge amount of noise and so trying to
understand well what's here to stay and
what's maybe a passing fat or maybe
something that doesn't really have
longevity does take a lot of effort that
makes sense and unfortunately I feel
like climate change is just so
politicized right now what's your
experience been like running a start up
in kind of a politically fractured
industry yeah you know the the policy
world is actually very new to me I'm
coming from kind of engineering and then
Tech and so I'm spending way more time
in DC than I initially thought I would
have been you know I think the biggest
thing to understand is you have to think
of these problems in terms of systems
and everyone has a slightly different
priority set you know you can bucket it
as right or the left in the US but the
reality of the situation is all these
kind of Global Systems whether it's kind
of climate change energy Food Systems uh
Economic Development or job creation are
all interl and so in a lot of time a lot
of cases it's all about just reframing a
particular problem so that people are
excited so a great example is the IRA
the inflation reduction Act is the
biggest climate change bill ever passed
in North American history and what got
it over the ledge was in many cases the
job creation element right how do we
create Great American paying jobs that
catalyze kind of climate Solutions so
kind of the right in a lot of cases get
what they need where they really want to
Economic Development and maybe in some
in some cases kind of more economic
growth but on the left case they
actually get the climate change
solutions they want so all about the
compromise it's all about finding that
win-win in a lot of cases what's the
kind of uh 1 plus 1 equals three yeah
exactly very cool is there ever a World
in which you could Envision selling your
company and if so what would that take
yeah it's a great question you know I'm
not going to sit up here and say there's
a you know there's a price for
everything but as far as we're concerned
carbon markets as a whole are going to
be around A1 billion do Market in 203
and environmental markets holistically
are going to be trillions of dollars by
that time so for us kind of through our
current lens we kind of view ourselves
kind of going the distance and becoming
a public Independent Business um that
being said if we feel like we can
amplify our scale and our impact faster
through some sort of acquisitive motion
I wouldn't you know you always have to
entertain the conversation but as far as
we're concerned we're kind of focused on
Going the Distance nice is there any
advice that you would give your younger
self that you wish you knew on like day
one of your company um that you wish
you'd know now yeah you know I think
particularly with new Eco systems I
would actually really encourage folks
not to
um not to assume that the experts know
that much more than you actually do so
you know we're a three and a half year
old business and in three and a half
years we've kind of positioned ourselves
to be on the bleeding edge of how
environmental markets are going to work
where we're working with governments in
the US the UK working with some some of
the largest companies in the world but 3
and a half years ago it was just me and
my co-founder eating pasta in in or my
one-bedroom apartment and so you know of
course that took a huge amount of effort
and it's you know 70 80 90 hour weeks
but that amount of effort even just
after three years it's still not that
much time and so I wouldn't kind of
doubt oneself if you're concerned that
there's a huge gap between what you know
today and what you actually need to know
just kind of get started and understand
where are the soft spots and how can you
create value very cool um so what's next
for you tell me about what's coming up
in 2024 what you're looking forward to
yeah I mean honestly just adding zeros
to what we've been doing right so you
know we talked about the idea of having
400 million tons under management I you
know next time we chat I hope it's kind
of closer to a billion or more fingers
crossed um and similar on on the supply
or the buy side where we want to
continue to scale these markets again
these markets are really small still
they're only a couple billion couple
billion dollars per year and we need to
make that bigger so for us you know we
kind of have a winning strategy already
so we just have to do more of it and not
get own way and finally what would you
like your legacy to be yeah so I mean
when I think about my legacy or or patch
generally I think the biggest thing is
just putting a dent in climate change
you know we need to be removing around
10 to 15 gigatons per year by 2050 yeah
and if we can be doing you know 5 10 15%
and actually attribute attribute that to
what patch is doing I think that's
really exciting that would be amazing
well fingers crossed that you accomplish
that goal got a lot of work
so much Brandon thank you so much
appreciate
[Music]
it